hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we are in
round 8 of our coverage the 2018 came to
this tournament we're halfway through
the tournament so far they're 14 rounds
and we've gone through seven so we have
seven more to go and that means that
every player is gonna be playing the
same opponents they did in the first
seven rounds but they will be flipping
the sides so today we have Alexander
Ganesha playing the white pieces going
against a Vladimir Kramnik his fellow
countryman in the first match round
number one when they played Vladimir
Kramnik had the white pieces and was
victorious currently at this match they
have both seen at Fabiano car who wanna
who's leading the tournament tie his
game one of the first games to draw on
the day and so they were able to be in
their game knowing that if someone were
to win their match they would be only
eight points behind Fabiano with six
games left in the Canada's tournament
with the winner of the candidates
tournament going on to play Magnus
Carlsen in November for the world
championship so this match means
everything to both of these players has
really separates them and gets them into
that leader group going into the final
six rounds of play so we'll get started
with Alexander starts out pawn c4 pawn
e6 a knight c3 pawn d5 pawn to d4 so
getting into the Queen's Gambit line I'm
not here to f6 and Knight to f3 pawn c5
all pretty common moves in the Queens
gambit pawn to e3 and then the Queens
gambit accepted line with pawns takes on
c4 don't always see black deciding to
take the pawn here on c4 but that's
exactly what a flat emeritus ides to do
Bishop takes back with c4 a pawn to a6
getting ready to push forward his pawns
who b5 brings the bishop back here to b3
pawn here to B 5 and then pawn up to e4
so we all all of a sudden say see you
gonna show up saying I don't mind if you
attack me on the Queen side of the board
I'm gonna go ahead and start pushing
forward in the center of the board
after the pond takes the night
recaptures and the misha pr2 ob7 not
really looking to exchange off the board
as white you know could have always
played Queen to d4 but does have the
advantage of going first has more
develop pieces no reason right now to
trade off your most powerful piece on
the board so Bishop to b7 controlling
the light squares and then pawn up to e5
attacking the knight Knight comes down
here to e4 and then castle on the Kings
side you know and this is interesting
because I feel like it's pretty easy for
white to just take here on e4 Bishop
takes on e4 that's fine Castle on the
King side yes this is very active bishop
it's not doing too much not really
attacking too much material or putting
white in a bind by a means already
develop most of his pieces gonna get the
dark square bishop out this bishops not
stopping that at all
but instead once white castles on the
Kings side then then I can come here to
see three after the pawn recaptures
White has an isolated pawn this is
definitely something that white prepared
for so he's comfortable with this
isolated pawn but generally something I
tried to avoid a lot of players will try
to avoid as well must have a very good
reason doing so so this was was an
option that he had but decided to go and
play with the isolated pawn Knight comes
down here to a c6 and then pawn to a4
now if you look at Ponte 4 it may look
pretty innocent but it's actually a
pretty tough move for black to have to
calculate it and figure out how he's
going to continue let's look at a few
options here one would just be let's
take this pond right here we have to
keep in mind as we're looking at that
this pawn and this Knights are both
attacking the square here on b5 s
important not just this pond but this
square here if the pawn were to take to
want to keep material intact here
Bishop to a four pinning down this
Knight to the king and the King can't
easily move away this dark square Bishop
has not
developed in the game state so this King
here on ei it's probably gonna be
hanging out for a while if Queens who c7
trying to add protection to this night
this is really just a game of building
up threats around this pinned piece here
on a c6 Queen to f3 attacking that a
rook over here to c8 rook to b1
attacking the bishop and both sides if
they wanted to could just continue down
this path Bishop back here to a8 still
want to continue to defend this square
here on c8 buts not want to be attacked
by the rook so Bishop back here a8 maybe
rook to d1 defending this D file and the
knight as well
Bishop down here to c5 attacking the
knight at some point there is going to
be an attack from white he can lead the
charge and after the exchange on the
board it's going to be very difficult
for black to come out of this okay if
first some reason decided to take this
this rook or this Knight all of a sudden
broke up here to b8 check and after the
the King moves then this rook is going
to fall there's just no great way for
black to continue now if we come back
and say after pawn to a4 okay well what
if we just see the knight take here on
d4 well now we're gonna see pawn to d4
and this no longer has an isolated pond
for for white which isn't too bad
there's still a backward pawn which you
can always threaten if you're black so
maybe this is something that black wants
to try and I think this is a pretty
decent option now pawn to b4 just trying
to push a little bit further making sure
that it's more difficult for white to
develop as much as he wants to and
keeping in mind that this allows him to
put even more pressure on this backward
pond here on a d4 so that's another
option that he had chose not to do that
instead one with the option of Bishop
down here to c5 now this is attacking
the knight on d4 but unfortunately after
the exchange black is gonna be
on the short end of the stick spawn
takes on b5 pawn takes rook takes here
on a8 Bishop takes here on a8 and then
Knight to b5 and this is where we talked
about earlier the knight and the pawn
were both attacking the square here on
b5 this Bishop coming down the c5 is a
good development move but it was doing
nothing to aid the exchange that was
happening on this Queen side of the
board so all of a sudden we have an
exchange that has occurred and white is
now up a pawn here it's a passed pawn
can eventually push this forward and at
the end of day you know I think White's
gonna end up being pretty good in this
position so after the rook our castle on
the King side then we see the Queen's
come off the board Bishop over here to
f4 so white says I have the advantage
now let's go ahead and trade off
material let's get the Queen's off the
board don't have to worry about that
let's limp simplify the game as much as
possible in the in game does seem like
White's gonna be able to push this but
it's not easy you know if you can just
sit here and figure out a very
brute-force tactic to push this pawn
forward it's very very difficult it's
gonna be a long tedious win if Alexander
gonna shake wants to go ahead and grind
this out to the very very end so we
continue with pawn to h6 wants to make
sure there's no back rank mate with a
rook ever coming to this eighth rank
here in the King can't move so upon to
h6 also stops any threat of Bishop to g5
at some point pawn to h4 and I'm back
here to e7 and then rook to d1 says hey
if you want to exchange the rooks off
the board that is completely fine with
me I'm Nick recognizing he needs to have
some material on the board if he wants
to overcome this pawn deficit and plays
rook over here to b8 attacking the
knight here on b5 now Bishop to c4
defending the Knights Bishop down to c6
attacking the knight Knight just decides
to move over here to d4 Bishop to e4
pawn up to h5 Knight down here to d5 so
blocking the center of the board
black does have control of that you know
stopping this pond from pushing forward
anymore
White's just gonna have to maneuver his
pieces around he has a keen here on g1
will eventually want to activate this
same as black wants to get his King
involved into the action start some sort
of attack and tried to gain some
momentum because right now it's just a
plan of can white push his pawn up the
board we see an exchange the bishop
takes and the bishop recapture so black
does have the bishop hair it's not
completely an open board state and right
now most of the action is on one side of
the board bishop pears really do better
if there's to pawn structures on either
side of the board Bishop down to e3
we're cover here to c8 rook to e1 and
then we see a lot of maneuvering from
both sides Bishop to c4 Knight f3 Bishop
to a3 and you'll see a couple things one
is black is going to really spend a lot
of its time maneuvering these three
pieces and that is pretty much yet and
white is gonna do very similar tactics
but he's also gonna be pushing up his
pawns and getting his King involved into
the accent so Bishop to d4 this is a
great outpost it's defending both of
these pawns on the board and the pawn is
protecting the bishop as well Knight
down here to the u2 Bishop to b2 and
this is interesting because both the
bishop and the rook here are both
attacking the pawns have the bishop were
to take here then the rook could just
come down and capture if the bishop
takes we see Knight to f1 it's always
interesting when you see this because
your immediate thought is okay well you
know two pieces here attack II miss this
is gonna be very good for black but it's
actually more protected than black would
like because if the bishop were to take
here then recover here to c1 this Bishop
is being pinned down
you know if the bishop takes then the
rook is gonna fall that's gonna be
extremely bad for black if we see some
other you know combination you know just
doesn't really matter how it could be
the bishop here takes on f1 sure King
takes but being the dais there's no way
to stop this
the bishop could take here on
three or likes just gonna lose material
from any other variation so instead we
see the rook come down here to see four
rook here to e3 Bishop to f5 a knight g3
attacking the bishop bishop swings back
to h7 King to h2 taking the long
approach Bishop here to see one
attacking the rook rook e2 and then you
see the Kings start to move around the
board slow and steady but that is
completely okay with Alexander who shook
he does halftime King here to e3 Bishop
back here c2 then all of a sudden King
to d2 and it's march to the long way you
know many many moves instead of just
coming this way but he recognized this
was the safest way to go about it and
now I can start to aid this pawn with
his King if he wants to at some point
Bishop here to b3 rook to be one
attacking both the bishops Brooke pretty
much has to come down here to a2 King to
a d3 Bishop to a for now the Knights can
start to get involved Knight to e4 very
central square this guy has a lot of
options if Hallie wants to continue King
to e3 Bishop to c2 rook here a1 Bishop
b3 pawn here to a g4 and many of these
moves that they are kind of going
through a similar motion sometimes or
even twofold repetition don't want to
get to threefold from White's point of
view because it would be a draw and if
you're not familiar to threefold
repetition the board states is the same
in multiple positions if he--if that
three times it would be a draw in the
game but both of these players
recognizing that it's it's just all
about this pawn here on c3 right now
black is not even spending time trying
to push forward with his pawns he's just
trying to play defense over here because
he realizes that for some reason one of
these ponds pushes past he has to worry
about two threats on both sides of board
it would be overwhelming so why can just
very slowly and methodically push up the
board on a king side while getting his
King involved and then only when the
time is right start push
forward with his pawn here on c3 now
Bishop to d5 King here to d3
centralizing Bishop e7 rook to b1 work
up here to a 8 and then pawn to f4 just
continuing the push here
Bishop to h4 rook to h1 attacking the
bishop bishop comes back here to d8 rook
here to b1 Bishop to c7 King III King h7
night up to d6 so still not very clear
when White's able to start pushing
forward black seems to be doing a very
good job of protecting any pushing from
White's point of view but Knight to d6
finally getting that night more involved
into the game King to g8 a truck appear
to be 5 so getting aggressive with the
rook Bishop to c6 rook back here to be
for a bishop to a d8 and this says hey
let's go and exchange material off the
board recognizing that's not the path to
victory for black decides to play Bishop
here to h4 Bishop to a d4 Bishop down
here to a g2 could have also tried this
ship back here you know too deep there's
just so many different options many of
them are the same from both sides but
Bishop down here to g2 rook down to be
to attacking the bishop and we see very
similar to fold repetition then after
Bishop to c6 not wanting to draw the
game now plays rook to b3 so it is a
little bit different but both sides not
doing too much differently in the game
Bishop to g3 and at this point and only
this point after you know close to 50
moves now we see the pond push forward
to c4 it's about time it's happening
it's happening it has moved we have all
waited for the moments and it has
finally moved pawn to c4 and we continue
Bishop back here to h2 pawn pushing
forward f5 and after the exchange here
on f5 with the night's king here to h7
Bishop back here to be 2 and then rook
to e8 so there's now a double attack on
this isolated pond both the bishop and
the rook attacking it only does have
this one defender with the bishop here
on b2 but that's okay very similar as
we've seen throughout Aleksandar vucic
is prepared for these when it seems like
both the bishop and the rook are the
attacking a piece all of a sudden he
plays something like Knight to d6
and pretty much stops that attack so
there's no way that the rooks are gonna
come down and take first because he
would just he would lose that exchange
and you know if the bishop takes well
then just though the rook is gonna fall
right here so that's gonna be bad so he
has to play rook here to e7 Y plays rook
up here to be a really expect in this
position Bishop takes Bishop recaptures
rook down here to e5 check yes the King
can come to d4 attacking the rook and
now adding an extra layer of security so
this pawn can start pushing forward here
but it doesn't equalize the material and
black does have the light square bishop
this does defend the square here on c8
which the pawn would promote to so I
feel like he has a fighting chance here
that's not the option he chose to
instead decided to play pawn here to f6
rook here to see a tandem bishop back
here at h1 this is a really questionable
move to me this Bishop here on h2 is is
a great piece it's attacking both of
these pawns as pawn can't take care on
f6 which white would really like to do
because then the night falls
okay well that's bad it's also just
adding another layer of protection here
white has to worry about the fact that
both now the pawn the rook and the
bishop are all attacking here the bishop
could easily just come to d7 still
stopping any sort of threat from the
pawn pushing forward still stopping an
attack here if the pawn were to push to
c8 also just forcing this rook to move
but instead it comes back here to h1 not
very involved into the action yes it is
protecting these light squares not
attacking any material though just feel
like there is a better option here
Knight to f5 rook check rook comes over
here to be 7 and then pawn takes here on
f6 and this is pretty underwhelming
I didn't want to see the Ponte could
easily just push forward with East six
look at how much more dangerous this
looks just not worried about material
right here he wants more threats and
this pawn this past pawn here on e6 can
start pushing forward she's had so much
threat to his attack the night here on
f5 has a great outpost as it pushes
forward it's being protected by the
Knights very easy for white to continue
in this position but that's not what he
did he played the pend takes here on f6
and then rook down to b3 in this
position white played probably the move
of the game so far maybe even that the
tournament so far but take a minute Paul
see if he can find the best move for
white to continue and the movie is
Bishop to c3 and we'll kind of dive into
why this was such a good move if we were
to see something like the rook take on
c3 giving up that material then all of a
sudden King to d4 this activates the
King it's attacking the rook the rook is
gonna be forced to move here so let's
just say the route comes back to b3 okay
you no harm no foul let's just go back
to the square the rook was at what is
now up and that bishop in material but
now pawn to f7 and you can see how big
of a threat this is and there's no great
way to stop this if the bishop can't
come here to DC because the knight is
attacking at so how does black continue
maybe Bishop down here to g1 check but
then King to e5 just adding to the fact
that can start to come up the board and
defend that pawn bishop to h2 check okay
King to e6 and there's no way to really
stop this threat now in the game
unfortunately you know black recognized
this insult and this is a fantastic move
and it stops the check here and there's
no way I can take this and it's gonna be
good and so black decides to go ahead
and take this pawn here on f6 which is
really the move that he had to make
because we kind of looked at just taking
that Bishop is not gonna be what he
wants to do here King here to a d2
and this does open up the door for the
bishop to take here on f6 also just
starts to get this king over to the
Queen side of the board for protection
Bishop to f4 Great King here to see to
attacking the rook and then the rook
takes when you see the bishop take here
on b8 Knight up here to Yeates Bishop to
c4 King to d2 and so now the King can
easily just maneuver as it needs to
widest up material he does have this
past pawn on the C file and without the
rooks on the board now it's just a
matter of in game execution that he can
go through and get the victory
it was interesting as we were watching
this both players had around a minute
left and the the timer kept going to
zero for both players even white and
we're like well this just doesn't make
sense because White's clearly winning
here there's no way he's going to let
that the time bank run out and from
blacks perspective we just kept waiting
from Vladimir Kramnik to resign and he
never resigned out out of all the
players in the field he is going to go
the distance as long as possible I think
over half of his games have gone like
something 60 something moves + which
many of the other players they're like
20 30 sometimes 40 moves fled micronics
likes to play the in game sort of that
magnus carlsen where i'm just gonna try
to grind in my opponent mentally I feel
like that usually
wholly works if you're playing the same
opponent for like an entire series like
the World Championship if you're
grinding down one opponent and you're
also physically draining yourself but
you're clearly losing and you're gonna
lose you might as well just resign get
your mind right prepared for the next
game no we're gonna spend 8 hours on a
game knowing that you're gonna lose just
just take the El and move on but we
don't see that we see Vladimir Kramnik
fighting fighting even in a losing
position King here to f3 King back to f7
Bishop to f4 this is where I thought
black would resign
you know this stops pretty much all the
threat
but we do not see a resignation Bishop
to addy for kingi seven pawn up here to
c7 getting here to d7 h7 King c8 a king
e to King d7 and then only after King to
d3 after 91 moves flat Amir Kramnik
decides okay I've had enough I will
resign in this position not sure Mike
into that 20 moves earlier but that's
okay congratulations to Alexander
granitic great game from him knowing
that he lost to this opponent in round
one now he has some Redemption playing
with the white pieces and he's only a
point back of the leader and he still
gets to face Fabiano if he can be
Fabiano and he's now tied with him so we
do have six rounds left so a lot of
chess to be played but Fabiana Caruana
is half a point ahead of the rest of the
field and Godot shook is now only a
point behind the leader so thank you
guys for watching this has been the
longest game we have a record as far as
moves in a long time so thank you for
sticking with me for those that did and
I'll see you guys the next video